alright here we are in a 2017 Acura TLX
it's a push to start
yeah all keys lost you can see pushing
on it put on the brake and got nothing
we're gonna have to force the ignition
on so ignitions off we're gonna do all
keys lost
alright force ignition off so we're
gonna hold this down there we are see
our security light right there okay
alright we got two keys stored it's
gonna about to erase them all we've got
the new key right here it is in here
shut it off security are our
flash in here ditions off okay we're not
gonna set it we have no slot here so
we're just gonna leave it here on a
center console switch back on your air
you can feel it blowing so we're on the
immobilizer light go out so we got no
immobilizer light so yes it went off
switch ignition off missions off switch
ignition on one two switch ignition off
one key stored that's it no that's it
we'll go ahead and disconnect
disconnected set our key we'll just
leave it here on the console
that's it 2017 Acura TLX all keys lost